thanks for being here thanks hi data for
having me a very excited to get this
talk before I give this talk I want to
just mention that right now in the other
room there's a cookie took a cookie
cutter talk quicker that's like a little
tool which like generates your
scaffolding for your app and there's
also a data science cookie cutter
template daily data signs cookie cutter
template and that is very handy to start
your project and have like reproducible
research or data science projects and I
would just encourage you to check out
this data science cookie cutter template
awesome okay my talk um gamification of
search on benders and swipes this is the
talk I submitted or the title I so
meters
but while preparing the talk I kind of
came up with this like spiritual title
which better describes what's really
happening here and it's about active
learning or how I learned or how I
learned to stop worrying and love small
data show of hands who knows active
learning here and I'm talking about
machine learning active learning not
active learning in the sense that I'm
cramming for an exam or something yeah
okay a few people good good good I'm
chef an author
I'm on github I'm also on github I've
been doing like data science machine
learning stuff for quite a while and
before that I was a roboticist and I
active that I actually used active
learning to like create smart behaviors
of robots whatever that means and now
I'm a data scientist at the amblyopia
machine company we do everything related
to data data science data engineering
ops consultant stuff so if you have
problems you you can contact us now of
course we're hiring right it's mandatory
to say I guess um gamification of search
so and in this context we are talking
about like Gator search in the car
context and
we reuse search all the time right and
quite often you have those little fields
you put in some information and then
your search space is narrowed down to
like a little subset and you add some
more information and you narrow down
your search area in arrow down arrow
down and hopefully hopefully in this
little subset they are the cars that are
really of interest to you right but
there are a few problems for one like if
you do it on a mobile phone it's a tree
annoying to do it right like typing on a
mobile phone and stuff and moving
sliders that's not a lot of fun and also
a more fundamental problem is that maybe
in this big black space there's really
the car that is like that you're
interested in
it's search it's not that black and
white I think it's more like a degree
like shade of gray maybe so and we know
like there are better and more fun ways
of searching like people in like
different fields use it like some
something is shown to you and then you
swipe all you like it or you and I don't
like you know people like this wiping
thing they swipe and swipe they swipe
all day it can't stop swiping right you
know what I'm talking about right yeah
I'm talking talking about this great app
that we developed to search for cars
which is similar to to this other
unnamed app right and this is a like a
fun intuitive interface and I could tell
you how we did it and stuff and I will
peeve okay but I think there's something
more here and we we all know there's
nothing quite so practical that's a good
theory so I'm going to talk about theory
here mostly and more specifically I'm
going to talk about active learning
theory so active learning what is active
learning I'm quoting here the key idea
behind active learning is that a machine
learning algorithm can achieve greater
accuracy accuracy with fewer training
Labor's if it is allowed to choose the
data from which to learns and I continue
an active learner may post queries
usually in the form of unlabeled data
instances to be labeled by an Oracle eg
a human annotator and finally active
learning is well motivated in many
modern machine learning problems where
unlabeled data may be abundant are
usually obtained but labels are
difficult time-consuming or expensive to
contain obtain sorry this is the
abstract from the active learning survey
by birth settle and that is a nice with
a book it's like 70 pages and it gives
you like a very nice introduction to
active learning you can just read it on
a weekend it's really understandable I
think and I'm showing that because it's
like a great book but also the guy who
wrote it you can barely see dry the guy
with a brown brown shirt and the support
vector machines
that's sir battles births metals I
always mix it up sorry this is a g20
demonstration a few years ago and this
is a Carnegie Mellon machine learning
department I think they're all there
they have like signs like support vector
machines Bayesian against discrimination
I really like that one free variables
and the green one here is also pretty
funny map map reuse Map Reduce map
recycle that's that's a good one
okay but active learning right what is
active learning really about I read you
this abstract and the abstract really
summarized quite well and I think the
essence of active learning are these two
points greater accuracy with fewer
training labels and actively covering
for data while labels for for given data
point and this greater accuracy with
fewer training labels I mean data
science is all about data right and I
think active learning kinda gives you
good data you don't get a lot of data
but the data you get can be very good
and with like little data you can
achieve like trained good models
and then the second point is that by
actively varying for data we completely
change this problem like all of a sudden
we have a sequential decision making
problem so it's quite different than
what we normally do in machine learning
or data science to bring that point home
like this is a supervised setting we
have our data X and we have our labels Y
for example a CatDog CatDog whatever but
now in a explaining setting we don't
necessarily have labels this is not
strictly speaking an unsupervised
problem but we have to decide where we
want to get data where we have to vary
right so the question is what is what is
an interesting point what what is
interesting and there there are many
possible answers so let's look at some
data here's the little data set and we
already have two labels right typical
classification tasks here's the decision
boundary so what is interesting we we
have many ways to decide we could say
like maybe it's a distance of two of the
points to the decision boundary right
but that is one way so maybe everything
in the in the darker area is interesting
or maybe we use a special model let's
say we use a support vector machine
right
the only real points that are interest
to us are potential support vectors
because only they influence our cost
function right so everything in this can
you see my mouse everything in the
between the decision boundary there that
is of interest basically or maybe we
have something else we have a Samba of
models that make the decision so we have
like two decision boundaries here and
maybe the disagreement between the
between the two models that that is our
our interestingness criteria so the
little data point at the at the bottom
might be might be of interest or let's
do something completely different
maybe we're interested in like something
like the biggest model change right so
let's assume we carry this one and this
is red right so our decision boundary
would change completely so maybe that's
an interesting point right all we have
something like a Gaussian process and we
use the uncertainty of our decision
boundary there too - yeah as a criterion
for for decision so what is interesting
quite a lot of these are interesting
they're broadly speaking and you should
look at the like active learning book if
you want to know more but like I'm
certainty in general is interesting
query by committee is very interesting
this there are lots of expected some
things like expected model change
expected error reduction expected
variance reduction etc and it really
depends on your domain on the model
you're using on runtime performance etc
but you have a zoo and you can choose
from it basically if you saw the the
keynote today I think X epsilon is also
used in some areas of the MLP world at
least the settles uses it in this
context and it's quite quite interesting
you I mean I showed like this little
example of classification but you can do
arbitrary things with it so for example
I use active learning to make this robot
in the world explore the world and it
had a model of the world probabilistic
model and I wanted to know like a lot of
things about the world so I'd like talk
that stuff and then gain some some
information some knowledge and the
transparency here of the objects
basically shows you how interesting they
are so the robot already explored the
world a little bit and then it updates
the brief and keeps exploring basically
so it's also active learning
but yeah not just a classification task
right and we used to create the behavior
of the robot okay
theory there was I think human
understandable theory
let's get that get back to the topic to
gamification gamification of search we
have our search space but it should be
more like a like a shade of gray assets
right so when we like swipe a car we get
some information about all the cars
basically and as we get more information
we update our belief right works and
it's also beautiful because if we get no
information we suddenly the the space
that we already scarred it is like
search for again so maybe in the
beginning as a dad like this car but I
said it because the car was yellow and I
don't yet like like yellow cars but then
I gave some more information and all of
a sudden these two cars in the red box
they are like of interest again right
maybe there's something like active
learning or something similar that we
can use I know
maybe any details you know as almost as
I plant this talk right so um there
there is something called multi-armed
bandit you're kind of familiar with a be
test boosts familiar with a/b testing
self hands yeah okay and who is somebody
with a be testing end vendor theory are
more more than a thoughts that's nice
okay in a multi untended scenario you
have you have a row of like the slot
machines basically and normally it's
called one arm pendants but if I call it
multi and benders and you you have to
pull the arms basically and get money
and then the goal is to get as much
money as possible probably speaking so
the problem statement is something like
this and I'm not joking basically find
multi arm benders step to play multi
untended using bender theory
and the third status profit this is the
literal problem statement of for the
stars great and step two is like spells
out here which which is kind of nice
which is rare of course you can do that
a little bit more formally and and let's
do that
so the multi-armed bandit problem
statement given a bandit with n arms
each eye returns the reward which
centered from a distribution which
basically means if I have like Bernoulli
arms with certain probability I get like
one totin when I pull down and now the
goal is I want to maximize the total
reward that I get overtime just
basically find a policy that allows me
to get as much total as many terms as
possible yeah okay and here is such a
strategy the UCB strategy
does anybody know UCB phew okay good
you CDs use the V stands for apart
confident bounds and that is a family of
greedy strategies that select the next
arm to playing to in the end to maximize
the reward it's not an optimal policy
but it's a it's a very good one and you
can actually prove that it's bounded
that it's like pretty good basically
yeah
um and it also traits of exploration
versus exploitation what does that mean
if you place a bandit and one arm gave
you like you played three times and you
got a coin every time right should you
keep playing that one or should you like
maybe try a different one maybe maybe
you know you have to trade off this when
I explore this good one or one I want to
sorry do I want to exploit the good one
or do I want to explore a little bit
more hoping that I'll find a better one
right
so this UCB strategy manages this
exploration exploitation trader for you
how does it work UCB basically has two
components with which it uses to
determine the next best vendor to pay
for one it uses the past performance so
I played it five times I got at oten
five times pretty good right but it also
has this exploration bonus which
basically tells you it's like a
trade-off of how many times you played
in total versus how many times you
played this particular bandit so if you
played like hundred times like in total
but this one arm you only played once
and then get a coin maybe maybe you
should play it a little bit more to to
get to get some coins right okay most
specifically there is UCB one to a
specific UCB strategy which goes
something like this initially you play
each arm once just to get some data
basically and then you play the arm that
maximizes this formula and again we have
two paths we have the the past
performance new the mean reward of a
given bandit plus the second term which
is the square root of 2 log n divided by
n I and I n is the number you played a
certain bandit looks complicated but
isn't forget the square root forget the
to forget blocks what you basically have
is n divided by n I and n is the total
number we played divided by the number
we played a certain bandit so if we
played as I explained before like 100
rounds in total but only played this one
bandit once we have hundred divided by
one it's a big number so we have a big
exploration bonus basically but if we
played one hundred total rounds and
played this particular bandit 99 times
we have a big number divided by a big
number it's a small number we have not
really a big exploration bonus right
that's the idea that's a bit abstract
right so let's look at a demo
okay the code is not really that
important now they are going to be some
graphs but I have to Bernoulli arms
basically one's more likely to give you
a coin the other one is less likely and
I'm going to play four rounds in the
beginning just have some data and some
more interesting graphs then just a
little bit annoying I can't really see
it from here
so you can see the formula you have the
green and the blue the green is the past
performance there was the MU which is
just the average of the reward we got
basically and then we have the square
root here and this is four divided by
two for the route the total number of
rounds we've played divided by two that
is the number we played the certain
bandit yeah so in this case the first
vendor didn't really return too much
reward the second bandit returned quite
a bit more reward and the exploration
bonus is the same because you both paid
them twice yeah and now we're going to
like pay a few rounds since you see what
happens basically you with me so far
yeah okay good so which bandit are we
going to play who knows I'll just wait
one so you start counting by zero right
okay right okay and what happened I'm
sorry so we played it and we got some
rewards so the mean reward is the one
the exploration bonus decreased a little
bit because we played it one more time
and on the left one the exploration
Bohnert bonus increased because we
didn't play it relatively seen to the
other one yeah so we are more likely to
explore there but still the the second
bandit looks better so let's play one
more round and we did we again got some
money the green stayed the same so one
here the exploration ball secretes to
the
a bit and for the left on the
exploration lot has increased let's play
one more round okay now they're pretty
similar and more specifically the first
one is a little higher value so we're
going to play the the first one right we
did it and we didn't get any money so
the green the past performance decreased
and also the exploration bonus decreased
so you can see that it's like a
trade-off here of past performance plus
the can answer and see or confidence
bound maybe of yeah how with pay that
compared to how often we have played in
total right I just play a little bit
longer but you get the idea whenever you
you get the coin your performance
improves basically and your uncertainty
decreases
[Music]
and what you can also see that the total
uncertainty the bonus decreases over
time so when we played quite a few
rounds it's less likely that the blue is
going to be pretty big yeah after
feeling that my arrow keys aren't
properly working
okay I'll just go back that's fine
oh yeah maybe this one the details
aren't very important here but the the
bottom line the pink line that's a UCB
version and it's pretty much better than
the most other exploration exploitation
strategies like greedy strategies or
simply UCB one and stuff they just do
quite well fine okay this this is behind
the this is crazy formula and there are
some theoretical justifications of why
this is a good formula but I'm not going
to into it it's real pretty interesting
and you should read the paper I've
linked it in the references okay demo I
already did that so what can we do now
we have these bandits and bandits
basically give us a ranking of which is
like a good arm or the quality of the
arms basically right but now we have a
hundred thousands of cars so should each
bandit each each car be one arm then
initially we would have to play a
hundred thousand arms just to get an
idea what what kind of cars we like
right and that is not idea right they we
can't do that actually like a hundred
thousand car seat even if you like
swiping you don't want to swipe hundreds
of thousands of times right so so what
we do we use one bandit for a certain
feature and a feature could be something
like the brands so you have one bandit
with arms for any brand so for Porsche
Volkswagen BMW all these things right
and you have a second bandit for the car
body and the car body and another car
person could be like something like a
SUV or like a mini car or coupe or
something like that and we have a first
bandit for the segment and this segment
is something like a luxury car a sports
car
something like that right but in theory
you could use like arbitrary features
right that you're interested in and then
each bandit here basically creates a
ranking for a given feature it tells me
that I like BMWs and that I like mini
cars and coops or something like that
right and this doesn't quite give us the
next girl that we're going to show right
but we have a ranking of features that
are of interest and there there is a
tool which basically doesn't do anything
else I'm that's not true
but elasticsearch is made for creating
rancors rankings from like search query
some weighted search queries and we
basically use the output of the bandits
as input to elastic search and then
elastic search gives us a bunch of cars
which match our current interests like
the output of the bandits yeah good we
are almost there
we're almost there I said that in the
beginning of the UCB algorithms you have
to play all bandits ones yeah they all
arms ones but but but the data is quite
biased like you were looking at the
brands and there are lots of Volkswagens
there quite a few of visuals or
something like that and they're very few
I don't know poached for example right
so if we just randomly sample from the
data that we have there there's a huge
popularity bias and we wouldn't get like
a good cast that cover the entire car
space right and we want a good trip
representatives of the data that like
cover the entire space so what we did
that we do we use some spouse PCA to
find a space the space components that
optimal optimally reconstruct the data
whoo there was a lot so what do we do we
breakdown the space into spaces that
really so nicely represented data but
and afterwards we did like a clustering
algorithm and each centroid of the
cluster is like a nice like a
prototypical sample of the data which
like nicely covers the entire space
right and now we have let's say ten ten
of these samples and of these clusters
and these are the things that were going
to show the user first and then he
swipes or she swipes and we get like a
good initial guess of the taste of that
person because the the representatives
are quite quite different from each
other and then yeah you swipe and it
actually works so it's cool um okay this
is how we use bend it or more generally
speaking like active learning to work
with small data and explore like the
taste of the person who's wiping was
mostly theory but we had app icon right
so I should have some pie data like a
Python conference so I should at least
mention some Python of course we use
Python all the way down everything is
done entitled with the usual suspects so
I could learn for all the machine
learning part clustering segmentation
etc we have a little rest web server for
a flask web server for the REST API and
the client then like the client the
Android or iPhone app talks to this web
server and we used elasticsearch to
generate the ranking and that is also
pretty scalable like elasticsearch is
made for that it's super quick okay I
say let some time range
okay conclusion so what did we learn and
I think what we really learned is what I
already told you that active learning is
a great way to think about certain
problems where you only have small data
and active learning can really help you
to gather data from from the humans or
any other process which like could label
the data which is expensive so maybe it
may be active learning is something for
you for something you're doing and you
could Co try it out it's a super
interesting topic and actually there are
very similar topics which are also may
be of interest if you like this like
sequential decision-making general
global optimization experimental design
based on reinforcement learning super
interesting and very similar from the
set up
also there are optimal solution in the
sense like based optimal and it's called
planning in the leaf space but mostly
it's like to expense with your country
you're doing you can't really do it and
oh yeah the last point there is
something called hyper band a relatively
new it's like a bandit algorithm used
for a hyper parameter optimization of
your machine learning algorithm and it
looks but it's like much better than the
usual patient optimization or grid
search or whatever you use there so
maybe check it out okay there was my
talk Thanks
[Applause]
all right thank you very much we'll move
to questions any questions from the
audience yes I see hands over there
thank you sorry if this is a naive
question a few slides before first stage
where you did the pca followed by
clustering and then it shows it vanishes
correctly the centroids of each cluster
was that Marla tricked my question was
okay the person labeled those five what
happens next how what kind of the second
step this is it yes yes so this is some
pre-processing step we've done before to
get like some good samples to cover the
space then the user swipes and sergeants
wives and we get information abuse
updates the bandits and after a few
patches or last like a few swipes we
basically ask elasticsearch to show us
new images you're completely right the
way I explained it is kind of like
backwards the pre-processing step here
is in the end but I wanted to show how
the swiping works first because without
that you don't really have context for
this yeah good question
Thanks another question read right at
the back father said correctly your
approach still only works for binary
choice like like dislike is any way to
make that for categorical choice so the
question was bandits only works for
binary choices that is correct and I
think in this scenario it's always for
binary choices i from the top of my head
I don't know but we can have a chat
later like I'm very sure that like
certain excess lining methods can deal
with something different yeah
hi thanks for an interesting talk bandit
theory is more about testing one bandit
at a time but here you're testing five
six bandits minimum at a time with a
single picture so how do you account for
that and how do you cope with it have
you down the violations triangle yes so
if you're asking me if my inner
scientist is happy with the purity of
this approach then then it's screaming
but but I mean quite often that that's
the case right like does it really make
sense I don't know it's kind of kind of
weird I I agree but the end result what
the user experience is quite nice and
really what does the machine learning
metric mean for some some business case
or for some user experience thing it's
you're right you're right yeah thank you
for your talk how would you handle
highly dimensional data where it is not
even dumped every object did you
understand me no sorry Oh
once again yeah how would you handle a
highly dimensional data where you could
not sample every point I mean this in
theory is high dimensional data like a
car data point has like lots of
dimensions right you have the engine you
have the brand you have the segment you
have the color you have like all of the
extras what we did here we we picked a
few like car body segments etc and for
each we had a bandit and that is kind of
how we dealt with it and every time you
give like information of like oh I like
this car you give us information about
oh I like this car type I like this
brand like this etc etc and we just mix
it up with elasticsearch which is maybe
not the cleanest solution but one swipe
gives us a lot of information about many
dimensions and we agreed to model it
here
there was another one somewhere we have
time for about one more question I will
do any more questions yeah okay and
benaderet asked two and the first one
would be how do you do with dependency
between the variables because the
individual bandits would be independent
of each other and the second one is how
important is it to go with good
centroids at the beginning so
dependencies between the different
features we have met a good question
we didn't model it explicitly but you
might imagine that something like a
luxury car in general is not mini
something like that so there's a certain
overlap which you cover implicitly could
you do better yes also take part again
centroid how important is are the
individual how important are the
original centroid how important other
yeah like from from this one here
basically how important are they we we
tried a bunch of different approaches
and different clustering algorithms and
different pcs and whatnot it really
depends on what user you ask and then
it's a user experience thing they should
be sufficiently far apart and then cover
the space but you could also think of
like other approaches maybe you like
pick one point at random and then like
take one that is maximum far away and
another one that is Maxim far away from
from these things it works yeah